[Music]
yes tonight's a professional motocross
racer an X Games gold medalist who's
here to do a stunt for us today his new
film Nitro Circus the movie 3d is in
theaters right now let's take a look
please welcome Travis I couldn't help
but notice you're pretty much on a big
wheel when you do that stunt and then I
and I know it's been modified a little
bit it's not quite not really but it
really is you're using a kid's big wheel
and let me find out that that's you
prefer you like using a child's big
wheel why I wouldn't necessarily say we
prefer it but like it was interesting
because we jumped in the Grand Canyon I
mean we're base jumping motorcycles set
on a ramp doing triple backflips
everyone you know three wide we're
almost you know dying people are like
wow well those guys are professionals I
don't know how hard that is you take a
big wheel you jump at 30 feet and you
you know you do a backflip or you set it
on top of skyscrapers and people were
like I'm jump to one of those that's not
easy
yeah people a lot of people have
experience with a big wheel and and so
this is something that makes it
relatable yeah things that are relatable
actually I mean we have some of it will
do there's one the gnarliest stuff and
be like oh that was intense and people
are like oh Bravo and then you do like a
slip and slide and you know wow that's
amazing
yeah that was better you you've made a
point that there this is quite different
from what they do on jackass you because
you guys are really almost approaching
this mathematically sometimes isn't that
right yeah well nitro physics I wouldn't
necessarily call it mathematics it's
like you know most of the guys though a
Nitro Circus are um you know our
athletes they're all top um you know X
Games gold medalists in different sports
and but I think the biggest years
between Nitro Circus and Jackass is that
you can take your parents and your kids
to Nitro Circus and there's no genitalia
in 3d not yet anyway
no ill not unless something goes really
bad
you have a yard sale really bad or
really right so okay so and but also
you're you're putting a lot of thought
we should we should preface it you guys
really do put a lot of thought into
these stunts and really try and
calculate how it's gonna work out before
you do it know without a doubt but most
the calculation is truly what we call it
nitro physics everyone laughs but it's
someone comes up to the ramp they're
like how'd that look like steep in the
ramp a little bit and we actually did
use math for one of our stunts we took a
bus jump with we put seven of our best
friends in a bus and we jumped at 200
feet over a big ravine about 50 feet in
the air and the mathematician said we
needed to go 88 miles an hour while we
put an old NASCAR motor and it was just
about broken because I always crashed
those into the wall it seems like
recently and what had happened was the
bus would only go about 82 but thank
goodness our mathematician wasn't that
smart I don't know if he passed whatever
classes he was taking because the bus
just greased the landing it was sweet
right right so here I'm happy he was
wrong yes we were - were you as you're
going up the ramp looking at the
speedometer going you you did oh I want
to show this because we're gonna get to
a real stunt in a second but I got to
show this you did a jump off of a
skyscraper and you were propelled in an
interesting way well this is a blob
skyscraper dump this is one of the I say
the more safe things we did but it was
also one of the craziest because of the
the risk involved thing kind of base
jump stunt you do and we didn't really
know like the blob it count was
awkwardly perched on us you basically
have a giant mattress and you had to
Elvis's heavy Elvis impersonators land
and and that was what propelled you off
of the skyscraper yeah well what's
interesting about that though is you
start flipping like we were just
wondering you know how you were gonna
get propelled up or sometimes you just
go straight up which would be horrible
cuz then you land on the building and
just tumble down that right right
fascinating profession let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
like you didn't clear the skyscraper by
much yeah well actually Erik Roner was
this we both did that one but Erik
didn't get out as far as we thought he
was gonna get out and then the thing
that went horribly wrong that our
physics didn't really think about was
that Tommy it was one of the fat guys
that jumped on to the blob
he actually got flung off the blob and
almost went off the building without a
parachute with no parachute yeah well so
that Elvis